All right, welcome to another zoom call number of questions. So let's jump right in reminder to all you that are new go to the member site use the member site trying to put his announcements in such in the member site.
One of that we have today, which is talking about the true right version 6.2.
So true right updated to 6.1 earlier this year, and I was very hesitant to use it because it had a lot of bugs in it. So anybody that started with us and not a right from us.
Prior to last week, it got 6.0 and because 6.1 is to have too many bugs now they've upgraded to 6.2 as of last week and you can't download 6.0 or 6.1 any longer.
So anybody that's new that got a right this week or last week, there it will be version 6.2. Now I have on our member site and on the right resources page of the members homepage and on the frequency site.
So you could go and download 6.2 and if you do, it's going to wipe out your programs just so you know so you're going to have to send your computer if you do do that, you're going to have to send your computer back to us because we have to put your programs in and it's a totally different operation.
Programs that any programs that were created for you or that you created yourself, but anything that we created for you would be in a different folder. So for those who just got their right, I don't know if anybody's on here who just got a right.
And it's running 6.2. Well, you already know that's actually created a video for people who are running 6.2 and it's on the member site in a couple of places and on the frequency course as well. So this video explains how you would get to your personal program.
And it's just two extra steps. It's no big deal if you never use the right before, but if you're used to version 5.0 or for people who live with us a long time or you're used to version 6.0, which we upgraded everybody to in 2001.
Then it would be two extra steps. You go, well, this is dumb. I have two extra steps. But it's just there, they're hoping to get it changed in by version 6.4. There's some positive upgrades. It was very, very frustrating week last week because multiple rights that we got shipped to us at bad boards.
And we had to, we were fighting with that until we figured that out and version 6.2 was a great and that was a big giant pain in the two weeks to so we got it all figured out now Jake at true life has been a wonderful help. He's just been, you know, really trying to get everything working correctly. They just upgraded.
You know, some things on 6.2 for us. So I'm very thankful for what they're doing. I do think as especially I do think the 6.2 is is is going to have more, you know, possible uses and the programs are the same understand so the programs.
So don't think oh, I should upgrade to 6.2 because the programs are going to be better or more powerful. No, the programs are all the same. There's no new programs. They're not better. They're not more powerful.
It's just what they're trying to get to do with the right in the future. So they're going through these program changes. So my suggestion again is if you're running 6.0 continue to do so.
But moving forward, if your computer goes completely and we need to get a new computer, it's going to have to be a 6, it's going to have to be a 6.2 or maybe 6.3 or 6.4 depending on when that happens. Maybe it'll be a totally different version and they'll be in the Soviet viewpoint. But
And then secondly, moving forward, we were trying to keep our costs down for our patients. And if you wanted a new computer, we were able to sell those at lower fee. They didn't have they only had 4 or 8 RAM, I think, which was fine to run the right. Good to say, I run my right at home on a Windows 7 computer.
So it's not that you need a lot of RAM to run your right code. But moving forward, we are going to use true right computers and they are much more stealthful.
It's just especially with the new 6.2 software, it runs better on a computer that has got a little bit more juice to it.
So that the cost is going to be the same as the cost of true right. But if you do get a new computer from true right, you're still going to have to send it to us in order for us to put on your programs because it's a little complicated on our part. We have to create a few file and we have to put your programs in that file in the document file to our display.
It's not something you can do. We can't just send you a flash drive to do that anymore. So that's not going to be impossible. So in the 6.2 programs, 6.2 program, it's not going to be as easy to send you a flash drive. Now you could do it if you're really super computer savvy.
But for most people, you're going to send your computer back to us. That means that you can watch that video. It's on the master page. No need for you to do it, but just for you to get a better idea what I'm talking about.
Okay, first question. These are some of the last weeks questions since to get recorded. My doctor is saying that I should cut back and vitamin A because my liver enzymes are going up.
I'm taking the 80k three times a day and he wants my vitamin D lower set 123 are these numbers. Okay. He also thinks green tea can be hard on the liver, but I don't want to cut back a little TV. Go. Thank you.
I would say that you could you're taking three a day of the vitamin 80k that's 15,000 I use of D. I'm not concerned with the a that's a good source a in the 80k. So I'm not concerned with the a in there. So I disagree with your doctor lightly.
But and I'm not saying that you need to decrease your D, but 123 is is good. It's right where you're at, but maybe you don't need.
And I said last week, you could probably drop the two or one of those a day. I do agree that green tea extract can be hard on your liver because 90% of green tea extract sold in America is loaded with toxins. The TV goal is not.
So I would not cut back for the TV goal. So it is that is not going to be hard on your liver.
I said to blood work over the weekend in love and inflammation markers are and keep getting higher. If you have any suggestions by CA 15 three hundred and 96 points in two weeks in the in the CA 2729 went down to 99 points in two weeks.
I said the results of the PET scan also. This is the first one. So it's a baseline can cancer die off cause inflammation.
Try to sort things out. So what can cause inflammation? First, it's doing mistletoe therapy that could cause inflammation.
If you have a lot of diet, that certainly can cause inflammation because diet will produce endotoxins that you have to deal with.
If you have another other, there's other possible reasons for inflammatory processes. And what's typically, if you're as it gives person indication that they're inflammatory markers, you know, is see reactive protein. So see reactive protein CRP is really is a measurement of breakdown of inflammatory cytokines.
So it tells you that there's some inflammatory process going on, which can be that can be a good thing. It can be so remember initial inflammatory processes are an immune reaction. So it can be an immune reaction. Your body is actually working cancer. That's why something that's like mistletoe therapy that's going to stimulate a strong immune reaction can cause increase inflammatory.
By surgeons cancer mutation report for my colorectal tumor biopsy showed I had a k-ros mutation. So k-ros genes do a number of different things, but they also function as tumor suppressor genes. So also the surgical pathology exam showed the cancer to be at no carcinoma.
This is the carcinoma that is categorized by low levels of catalyst enzymes.
I ran across several papers for k-ros gene variants and cancers with low catalysts are good candidates for IV vitamin C.
I said last week that I wasn't sure that but you showed these reports of the study. So it's very interesting. I love my patients. You guys do more study than anybody out there. So
good news. So I did say last week because they get recorded that your program is written for and of carcinoma because that's what came up in your testing. So I didn't look up your practice reason to cook and look at that. So that's good.
So remember k-ros mutations are one of the tumor suppressor genes. So there's numerous gene families that function as tumor suppressor genes.
And there the gene families also have other functions other than tumor suppression. So remember what a tumor suppressor gene does. So they are genes in your body in the cells that if the cell starts to go through rapid replication because of something.
So remember once a cause of cancer or something that gets inside the cell can be a toxin can be a virus can be a bacteria can be you know a fungus can be anything that gets inside the cell that damages the DNA.
And then the cell goes in and starts to go into rapid replication and it replicates cells that aren't also damaged in that DNA in a rap state of rapid replication.
Well, that happens. It should kick on your tumor suppressor genes.
Most common one that maybe you may have heard of is the P53 gene. That's the most most research tumor suppressor gene. The first one that ever was discovered.
But also the bronca gene. Everybody's heard that. So bronca genes are tumor suppressor genes. If you have a lot of defects in your tumors suppressor genes like your bronca genes.
Should you just get your organs removed? Well, I think that's absolutely idiotic. But people have done that.
They have multiple double allele defects in the tuberous suppressor gene so they just get their breasts removed and their ovaries removed.
I just don't understand that logic. A tumor suppressor gene doesn't cause cancer. A tumor suppressor gene though.
If you have defects on that gene, it cannot kick in so that it won't stimulate a part of cancer death. So there's two processes of program cell death apoptosis.
There's an intrinsic apoptosis that takes place actually when a tumor suppressor gene kicks on. It kicks on an intrinsic apoptotic reaction. So the cell goes into more feed and blebbing and destruction and basically recycling breakdown of that of that cell.
That happens every single day with people every day. And if it didn't we'd all be dead of cancer by the time we're five years old. It's happening every single day.
So just because you have a carousel mutation doesn't mean you're going to have cancer just because you have bronco mutation does not mean you're going to have cancer.
But it does decrease that intrinsic now when we're working with the right when we're working with the immune system we're trying to stimulate cancer death.
We're all we're working on and it's the only way you can is you're working on the extrinsic apoptotic pathways. So the extrinsic apoptotic pathways are from the outside of the cell you're trying to get that cell to go through cell death.
So it reminds me I'm going to make a note. I'm going to send you.
You're on the call that I said you the other things that will help with k-ros mutations that are known. I think it was curcumin and some other things but I won't do that again.
I made a note of it on the last call last week was it was so discombobulated last week. I apologize. Computer didn't work.
And it cut out at the end and then we had so much trouble with those right machines. It was.
It was a rather stressful week. I had to take a whole bunch of adaptions.
But it's important for you guys, but I will send you that clip.
Okay, thank you.
I said in lab results by inflammatory markers are high. I have been on prednisone for a couple days. Can I send a cheek swab in and I made mention that might be better to wait till you're off the prednisone.
What's the best type of glutathione take and where should you get it and can a person who has estrogen driven cancer take it.
The best type of glutathione is liposomal glutathione. You can get it from us. We have the liposomal glutin clear but there's multiple companies that carry liposomal glutathione.
Typically any nutrient that's wrapped in a fat, you'll have much better absorption and that's the key. You can take a supplement and you don't absorb it. You just deposit the toilet. It's completely worthless.
So you have to have good absorption and glutathione that first came up did not have good absorption. They've improved it multiple times and now went to advocate liposomal glutathione that's by far the best.
Oh, here I did. So last week I did I copied and pasted it right on here. So I remember. So possible interventions with Keras mutations are glutamate scavenger EGCG which is green tea extract catagons, curcumin, a keto like diet time restricted eating and I would also add the possibility of enzyme therapy to that too.
Dr. Kelly's enzyme therapy. I might add that to that too.
So Dr. Kelly's enzyme therapy is, I think you know what that is, but what that is is and is using high dose enzymes on an empty stomach.
So you recommend using protein zine powder for me. I do not like it. Please recommend an effective substitute for protein zine in capsule or tablet form.
Well, the problem with taking a protein powder in itself is that I don't think taking a protein powder is as good as just eating some protein.
So because you can have two scoops of a protein powder that is still going to get maybe 20 to 25 grams of protein.
So well, that's good. You know, if you're eating a smoothie any how you can throw that in there. So it's great. Now, you know, I always take my smoothie maybe daily.
So if I add the protein powder, I'm just I'm just getting protein. So it's hard for me to eat the piece of chicken, you know, at that same time, because my stomach's full.
So then you add the protein powder. It's not going to make you any more form.
The problem with putting a capsule for two scoops or a scoop of protein powder. And even that would be 10 capsules. You know, so I don't, you know, there may be some protein powders that come in capsule form.
A lot of capsules to be equivalent. So I will look for you for that.
The protein side is in vanilla or chocolate. The other protein powders that I think are good. We carry one from designs for health. I think is good.
It doesn't taste it. I mean, I know all of them have the same flavor.
So I don't know if you'll find one that you like as far as powder goes.
My recent blood test shows some academia. I think you may have said that taken an iron supplement for someone with Hodgkin's little trouble was alright.
Would blood builder by mega foods be fine for about 30 days.
So let's look at this. So this person was kind enough to give the ingredients of this blood builder by mega foods.
Okay, so I heard as fermented I heard this glycinate. Good. That means it's a double bond to glycine.
So that's a good form of iron right there. Okay. Whole food. Good form of iron.
Well, the good news stops right there. Unfortunately, because B12 as cyanokabolamine is the wrong. That's a synthetic B12. That's knocked the form of B12 you want. You never want to take something with cyanokabolamine.
And then this gets even worse. Folate as folic acid.
Folic acid is synthetic folate, which many have hypothesized scientists have hypothesized the increase of the use of synthetic folate, which is folic acid.
It has what has caused the MTHFR defects in people. So this is like this should be outlawed. I mean, literally this this product folic acid should be outlawed.
So any company still using folic acid. They're the dark agents. This is really bad. This is what's actually added to enriched foods that makes it so bad for you.
Vitamin C is a score of a gas until a 15 milligrams. It's probably incidental organic beetroot. That's fine. Food blend. That's fine. Good. These two things.
This especially is poison. So do not take this. Take our clear iron. Use that product instead of clear fired.
Also, you know, eating foods that are beetroot is good for you. That's a good thing to help build your blood, especially this time of year. You could get that readily.
Come over to my house. I have it growing in my garden on my recent swab testing you added clear GI to my supplements.
But on the store, it says those with cancer should not take that product. This product. Yes, I wrote that.
Just curious why it is for me because we have to feel your your your gastrointestinal tract.
So this is the best got healing product on the market with the least amount of glutamate. That's why we private labeled it.
And we've been using that product for gosh, 15 years. Great product. I don't just I don't give it to cancer patients.
Really, really. Very few people I recommend it for a tested well on you for your God. It's not going to be something you're going to be on for a long term.
Has a low enough food to mean that I'm not concerned about it right now. And it just got so many other really good gut healing nutrients in there. So also, how do I know when my God is healed. Well, we don't know when you're about as healed.
You, we're just going to we're just going to have to have another communication and meet a moment of a month. You have to give yourself a month to six weeks. And the truth is, is that, how do I know when my God is healed. You're God has never healed. It's constantly breaking down and being damaged by what's the number one thing that damages your God.
Astrocytes, GMO foods, glyphosate, food sensitive needs. And if you're eating foods that you have antibodies to let's say I have antibodies to go to then you're eating gluten every time you go you're causing an inflammatory process in your gut and your brain and your skin.
And elsewhere your lungs and you're just there's no way you could heal it. So you have to look at food antibodies. That's the benefit of doing the Syrex 3x4 rate 10 test rate 10 tests 100 different foods different ones cooked in raw.
And it tells you if you have food antibodies antibodies to different foods that you need to lay off for a period of time tells you really, you know, if your gut is an issue, you know, so then we that we need to work on. So there's other reasons why I personally have problems, but certainly they got wall is one of them.
So getting that tested. So that's why we want you to eat organic. That's why we want you to stay away from GMO foods. That's why you, you know, don't want to be on, you know, you want to try to avoid medication that's going to damage your gut as best you possibly can.
Well, sometimes there's no way to get in around those things. And even if you eat perfect and do everything perfect, you're still going to be exposed to different chemicals, different toxins, different cross reacted things pesticides that are in organic foods, even that are going to damage your gut. So whatever completely heal it's always a process.
So that's a thing to remember.
So we'll check back and so you can you when you add food, when you do the rate and let's say on the Syrex array 10 and you have yellow things and things in the yellow things in the red that means it's their positive.
I mean, you have antibodies to that food and you stay off for a period of time and you start adding things back that are in the yellow range and you're watching for any reaction in your body.
That's one way to do it. You're slowly adding things back. Another way to do it is to recheck and do another test.
So that's another way to check those things. And the truth is it we could take a thousand people off the street and run the Syrex array 10 on them.
And I would bet that almost a thousand would have some issues. That's how prevalent this has become in our society because especially in America, you know, you go over to Europe.
You know, you know, because of the bad cow disease, giant scare that people died up in the 80s, literally everything is organic.
But you know, there's nothing that is no all GMOs and everything are banned. So, but America allows these things, you know, and we're suffering because of it.
The rate of autoimmune disease is going through the roof and it's it's just has gotten to the point where it's not boy, I hope I don't get an autoimmune disease. It's a wonder which one I'm going to get because, you know, because of our environment, it's.
I don't want to be Debbie Downer, but just about everybody's going to have an autoimmune disease in the United States.
Well, that's why I wrote that course on the chronic disease and autoimmune and that's why I think it would be valuable for even though we are dealing with cancer, you know, if you're not in a crisis mode with cancer, it'd be good to start going through some of that information.
The question of Dr. Jen's Facebook group, Dr. Jen is practitioner in Pennsylvania or Virginia or something over there and she says she just interviewed me for her breast cancer.
I think that's coming out of January, so I just talked to her and interviewed her on my podcast a couple times, I think she's interviewed me a couple times.
I really like her. She was a breast surgeon who just gave it up because she just said I'm doing more harm than good and she wanted to help people in a different way. She just was led to help people in an actual way. She's learning functional medicine and try to help people in that way.
Asked a question of her on her Facebook group about formal blockers to reduce tumors.
And if it works, even though estrogen doesn't cause cancer, Dr. Jen said that estrogen positive cancer tumors mutated themselves by making more estrogen receptors and therefore decreasing estrogen temporarily through like normal taste inhibitors may temporarily shrink bulky tumors.
This made sense because I remember my college is even saying that sometimes the or the taste inhibitors stop working.
I then asked her if circulating tumor cells and any cancer phone in the lymph nodes will have the same receptors as that original tumor she said not always, which is true.
So you could have cells and the same cancer cells at different spots that may not be our positive PR positive or her two positive or negative as what they biopsied. That's not our comment.
And so I am trying to figure out when to stop the horrible blockers because I do not intend to take them forever.
I think this person's oncologist wants them to take it for them. I think that's kind of what's typically recommended.
My best activity is next week and I'm supposed to take another out of home blockers this Friday. Can you tell me if Dr. Jen's explanation makes sense?
If I am making a reasonable assumption that any circulating tumor cells or possibly lymph node involvement, I won't know the terms of surgery if that's true.
But have any extra receptors will be your positive.
Yeah, I don't know what the percentage of that possibility is that'll take anybody can tell you that.
I think it's a reasonable assumption that the blockers would possibly protect me until we can take a closer look at why this mutation occurred in the first place.
I hate the effects of the blockers. They're long term and convinced they're helpful.
And I want to do what's best then I'll send you a cheek swap three days after surgery as we discussed to see if the hormones are still coming across.
I think you're just as it's another example of you guys just being so brilliant in doing your homework and trying to figure this out yourself.
Bottom line, I know Dr. Jen mentioned that you just got a trust you got.
I wouldn't use to use that terminology. I really think you just need to pray about it and listen to the Holy Spirit and what he's telling you to do.
Sometimes you know, I met you to a person today, sometimes God allows trials in our life. I know he never God doesn't tempt us to sin.
But that does allow trials in our life for the purpose of moldiness and shape it as more to the image of his son. That's what sanctification is.
He allows struggles in my life to mold me and shape me to be more like Jesus and sometimes I'm embarrassed as a result of the trials because I don't act more like Jesus and and God has to teach me another way.
But that's what his goal is you become a believer is to mold you and shape you to be more like his son and sometimes trials drive us to a deeper relationship with him so that we can get answers that we need or just trust him in a deeper way that we've never had to trust him ever before in that way.
You see in America to call yourself a Christian and you never go through struggles, never go through problems.
You think about the Christians in other countries, just this morning on mission that worked is listening to six people in Libya, that Libya is a Muslim country, six people that have become Christians.
We'll soon become executed just for their face. But we don't go through any of that kind of stuff.
And you know, cancer is another type of trial, but all our trials are to drive us to him in a closer relationship to him.
I've always wanted to know why they say if you never, if you've never been pregnant or breastfed, that you have a higher risk for cancer, both true in my case.
Why is that? Because if you've been pregnant and him and especially if you breastfed, you've used the cells, the lactation cells for the purpose that they're created.
And, and by breastfeeding it's and they've been done studies with women who breastfeed longer have a lower risk. So if you stop breastfeeding at three months, and we need your baby at three months versus breastfeeding for two years, and the baby naturally leads off when that baby doesn't want to breastfeed anymore.
Those women have a lower risk of breast cancer, and it's has to do with the use of the breast tissue. So when you use the breast tissue, and, and you know, it's, it's functioning the way it's supposed to function and creating milk, and you do have a lower risk of cancer.
Would GCMAF injections be a possibility for me this person is something I talked to recently had a neck cancer, either before or after chemo possibly yes, you know, the
inherent problem with GCMAF is, is the question whether the current manufactured GCMAF is the same as what was manufactured in Europe, a decade or so ago that got shut down seven years ago or something like that.
And they just got run, they got shut down the orders, I think got jailed. Well, then it started to be created again in a lab started creating it again, I think the Philippines.
And there's argument that that that it's not the same.
But I know there's practitioners that use it, so I don't know we can't use it here in this office, but I know there's practitioners use it, they think that it works well.
You mentioned that it's too late to fight the cause, but time to fight the cancer.
No, let's, let's make sure we understand it's never too late to fight the cause, it's never too late to deal with cause, let's say my cause of my cancer is was a toxicity.
Well, if something gets remember cancer is something gets inside the cell, it could be anything, anything that gets intracellular inside the cell and damages the DNA, it damages the DNA and causes the DNA to go into a rapid replication, replicating cells that are in rapid replication now with that same damage DNA.
Now fighting getting rid of the cause is is important to detox that you get rid of that so it doesn't get in another cell and cause cancer again, you know a totally different cancer so it's so important to deal with the cause plus cause is more than just what specifically damaged the DNA causes, you know, why did I have a suppressed immune system?
Why, you know, why is my parasympathetic system down? Well, you know, that's why people under a greater stress have an increased incidence of cancer.
So there's lots of pieces to that cause too that you have to deal with that you are dealing with that we make you guys deal with when we're trying to treat the cancer so you are dealing with the cause.
I didn't say it's too late to fight the cause you are dealing with the cause, but you also have to kill the cancer cells so just because let's say I could let's say I couldn't wave a magic wand let's see the cause of my cancer was toxic and if I wave the magic wand and that coxins were all out of my body just like that.
Well, the kids are still growing so the damage the damage was done it's not continually damaging and the damage was done so I still have to kill the cancer so just because that's why I mean otherwise we would just be toxic you guys and you wouldn't use a knife and you wouldn't stimulate your immune system and we would be talking about this until we wouldn't be talking about possibly chemotherapy.
We would have to fight the cancer because it would just go away so it doesn't work that way once the damage of the DNA is there you still have to kill the cancer so understand you have to deal with the cause and if you don't it's to your demise.
You are all our patients are but we also have to kill the cancer so your book you mentioned lay a trail needs time to build up the therapeutic doses well that's true really everything does you start taking mushrooms it's going to take a few weeks to get really to therapeutic doses meeting that builds up in your body to really start killing the cancer.
Same thing with lay a trail but I think I in the book I said that because there was a study about that.
Would that be something that it's too late to do something I don't have time for no I would say no I would say you still there's still time for that.
My glyphosate test came back still very high after two years of detox and idiot organic does this surprise you at all how can I get rid of this you know this is this is really sad because.
Because it's this is what we're talking about before was that you could do eat perfectly and you're all you eat is organic why would I possibly have glyphosate test high because the truth is you get you could get glyphosate you know through organic food it's cross contaminated you can get glyphosate from you know you know it's great.
You know in public places there's rain for weeds and and and things so it's it's it's so prevalent in our society that's why I said it's there's this is why the rate of cancer has gone through the roof this is why the rate of autoimmune diseases have gone through the roof the rate of chronic illness has gone through the roof because we are being systematically poisoned and.
You know there is there isn't like a perfect way to get rid of glyphosates so we just continue to work on detox pathways and continue to support detoxification now we're dealing with this wherever chemicals that are in everything they just they just tested toilet paper every toilet paper they tested head forever chemicals on it.
But what are going on it's like it's like they're doing it on purpose or something I didn't say that I just said it's like they're doing it on purpose or something it's insane so it gets depressing and you just got to go yep i'm not going to get down about it it's going to keep doing everything I know to do that's right it leaves it wants to go on that's the only way that you can deal with such insanity well I haven't seen the actual lab yet my doctor.
sister was called by lab core that I am a neemic and I heard was very low not so low for ER visit so what they'll the ER visit if you're.
The I heard is low they'll look at your hemoglobin so if your hemoglobin is below 7.5 then you do need to get in and get a transfusion if your hemoglobin is still 10 but your I heard is low.
So your red blood cell count is low then you don't need a transfusion but then you do have to think of supporting.
The low I heard also in your case and you have to look at is there any possible bleeding because of your type of cancer so you always want to whatever you have a demon you always want to ask whatever you have anything you want to ask the question what question why why.
Can you have anemia in cancer because the cancer is gobbling up some higher yes you can can you have anemia anemia in for any reason because you have your losing red blood cells through bleeding yes so you do want to investigate that maybe want to do it'll call blood test which is blood which is a swab stool sample swab.
A little blood test for that it's very simple and see if there's any if that's a cause so we need to look at that also.
But not a load off they call also my B12 was low I do have a partial empty HFR defect this is the first time she has ever called by a lab with awarding for a patient so the B12 being low that would be a concern to you could have B12 anemia that would be good it would be better it's better easier to correct.
He needs a B12 would be just fine I would suggest the hydroxylcobalamate and or the adenosylcobalamate besides eating liver et cetera I noticed there are products online for ancestral and heart soil where they have freeze dried grass fed blood livers lead low-wide products.
ECB vaccine I got some I think those are fine any other suggestions sorry don't have actual lab results yet I'm not sure what is driving this I was having blood in stool regularly but since June 15th I've only seen it twice so let's see those labs and then we'll go from there glyphosate 2.5 that's just very frustrating with the glyphosate just.
Is it safe to put castorial packs on swollen lymph nodes you can try it everybody's a little bit different how you'll function with castor oil and or function with heat over swollen lymph nodes
And the reason is some people's bodies react in a negative way to it so I just go slow and try it for a couple minutes and see how you react and then slowly add time some people do better with heat some people do better with cold.
Now use heat on the castorial packs some people don't do well with castorial packs over the belt some people do well so you just get to try it.
The GCMF the order is now out of jail second time even after being extradited to France by the UK I believe the UK based lab called first immune is now manufacturing GCMF that would be fantastic again also an Ecuadorian that your parents has by available for shipment in the US.
Well thank you for that this is a good information so whoever's looking for that ask that question can copy that address though and look that out.
Should I get the after surgery supplements and start taking them right after surgery or wait for the cheek swan wait for the cheek swan because that might change with you so I wait for the cheek swan.
Okay last questions here all right we will call it a night thank you for being on today no one that I'm praying for all of you and fighting the good fight.